bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream pour cette demi-finale du
championshistour alors je vais vous
montrer un petit peu les joueurs qu'on
va avoir en lice aujourd'hui vous avez
ici le tableau avec Magnus Carlsen qui a
gagné hier 2 et demi à 0 et demi au
tabac Tabe qui va affronter aujourd'hui
carwana carvana Wenger à l'Armageddon
hier contre la zavie et ensuite dans la
deuxième partie de tableau on va avoir
so Wesley kerenia 3-0 contre elianov
contre Furious Jacky 3-0 contre à
boussottov donc en tout cas deux gros
duels ici qui vont être hyper
intéressant à suivre
et dans la poule des perdants et ben on
a je pense un petit peu les les
appariements qu'on pouvait plus ou moins
deviner hier on a tabatabeilles qui joue
contre l'azalik
et on a aussi Eliano qui joue contre
Abdou santorov donc voilà encore une
fois deux duels qui sont qui vont être
très intenses donc moi j'aime mes
favoris dans cette compétition je sais
pas si vous vous avez des favoris dans
dans ces tournois en tout cas dans ces
dans cette compétition si vous voulez
bien sûr on peut le partager sur le chat
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire en tout cas
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous En
Saint-Laurent l'ouverture bonjour à
buguenard
et bonjour à tous alors on a aussi dans
la deuxième division alors
malheureusement je peux pas vous le
montrer à l'écran parce que je n'ai pas
accès à ces scènes là sur mon ordinateur
enfin en tout cas sur mon Obs et du coup
on a Laurent Freyssinet qui a gagné hier
contre dreyev et qui va jouer
aujourd'hui alors je vais vous dire
juste une petite seconde contre qui va
jouer je les ai apparemment je vais
avoir ici
attendez là vous sortir je peux pas vous
le montrer mais je vais vous le montrer
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il est en train
de louer
s'il est en train de jouer on va le
suivre notre ami Laurent Freyssinet
je le cherche et là il va le contre
artemief et la partie a déjà commencé
donc on va si vous voulez passer à la
partie de
Laurent Freyssinet contre artemiev ici
devant vous
et ensuite donc freiner Laurent presnay
elle est blanc dans cette partie et
la division 1 commencera à 17h15 un
petit peu comme d'habitude salut Cécile
salut Yume le gagnant de winner raquette
une seconde chance oui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est bon nous deux bonjour à toi et
bien évidemment alors
pour être éliminé il faut perdre deux
fois donc ce serait franchement ce
serait vraiment
pas pas cool si tu gagnes tout en finale
tu perds contre le joueur qui a fait le
sous-marin derrière non il faut que tu
me battes deux fois c'est ça
et salut à tous on est sur Youtube je
vous vois aussi je vous lis bonjour à
tous bienvenue
donc là on fera signer qui joue contre
artemière donc Laurent les blancs dans
cette partie donc c'est une Française
d'avance
avec fou des sets de cavaliers
on le voit souvent et F6 Caval et vs 5
qu'on veut venir toucher la case des 6
donc cavalier G6 a été joué et après la
prise prise H4 on veut essayer de
chasser le cavalier en V6 c'est un coup
assez assez normal assez
assez logique et après faut cacher
mais on a qu'à une position intéressante
au centre il y a eu A6 chez les Noirs
donc là on peut imaginer un coup comme
cavalier C3 je pense
est-ce qu'on peut aussi éventuellement
regarder le courage 5 est-ce que c'est
un coup qui est intéressant
ou est-ce que on va juste faire cavaler
C3 qui a l'air aussi tout à fait normal
donc si
Laurent si Laurent
réfléchit c'est que regarder enfin
réfléchir à l'avantuctualité de faire
caler ces trois je pense parce qu'à
chaque hyper intéressant H5 si vous
mangez là je prends là vous voyez et là
il y a un visage entre les tours pas
trop trop mangé
et donc ça ressemble étant j'ai
l'impression dans les orages 5 peut-être
que le cavalier mais alors pour aller où
peut-être aller ah il est reparti
la porte ouverte
et mon chat qui fait des fois des
petites des petites bêtises
donc avec ces trois été joué
et les Noirs je sais pas comment ils
vont continuer alors je pense il y a
plusieurs possibilités ici alors petit
orgue c'est pas trop un truc qu'on a
envie de faire vous voyez bien avec le
roi qui quand même assez ouvert
peut-être essayer voilà
vous décises bouger la dame et grands
peut-être possibilité
pendant que les blancs vont plutôt jouer
je pense sur la
5 peut-être faire un G3 ou un G2 et
essayer je sens qu'un jour etc
donc
intéressant en tout cas cette
cette partie on a aussi dans la division
3 alors j'en ai juste pas encore parlé
dans la division 3 et ben on a aussi un
très très gros match c'est le match de
Étienne Bacro donc connu ici sur Baki
tout le monde le connaît je pense et il
joue alors il a un très gros adversaire
le pense qu'il n'aurait pas pu avoir un
réservoir plus gros donc il a passé deux
tours hier je peux vous montrer hier
j'essaie de voir s'il y a les parties je
regarde un
je crois qu'elles sont pas été lancés
encore je vous souhaite refresh
partie de la division 3 ah si elles ont
commencé et je disais qu'il a un très
très droit adversaire Étienne parce
qu'il joue ma média off en aller-retour
pareil donc la cadence c'est 15 + 3 et
on est du coup en aller-retour
[Musique]
on a rien vu
on a rien vu du tout
scène
et donc donc voilà 15 + 3 et ma mère
c'est pas c'est pas enfin c'est un bon
client quoi donc il y avait dans la
catégorie enfin dans le troisième tour
de cette de cette ce tournoi en division
3 il y avait quand même d'autres joueurs
qui étaient un peu plus accessible comme
il faut le taper on a pas le choix
l'avantage c'est ma média off c'est un
joueur qui est qui est qui veut gagner
tout le temps qui est très agressif et
donc du coup je pense que tienne avec
les Blancs il aura sa chance il aura sa
chance contre ma média Rohff
qui veut tellement gagner que des fois
il prend des risques des fois un peu
inconce et bon Étienne c'est Étienne
arrivé très solide très très fort et du
coup bah il a clairement sa chance il
peut gagner le match mais c'est pas le
plus facile il a pas l'appareil le plus
facile pour l'instant
la partie je vous lance début si vous
voulez et pendant ce temps là je vais
surveiller que les gens arrivent en plus
ça n'est pas encore toutes les caméras
donc c'est plein de choses alors B3 qui
en récupère le pion
en C4
et c'est une ouverture qui est assez
solide de la part des deux joueurs
de la part des deux joueurs c'est assez
solide
c'est assez solide
ok voilà
donc ça c'est la partie de la rentrée
sinon je bouge un peu entre les entre
les différentes parties c'est de voir et
pendant ce temps je vois si les gens
sont arrivés parce que dans la caméra
mais j'ai des caméras que des que de la
première division que la première
division j'ai des caméras j'ai pas les
caméras des autres et par rapport à ça
et
il me manque encore beaucoup de joueurs
qui ne sont pas encore arrivés sur 8
joueurs j'en ai que 4
autres qui ont décidé de pas venir pour
l'instant c'est les quatre meilleurs on
a mal aux 45
erwana saut et firouzar les quatre ne
sont pas encore arrivés
dans le studio et donc je peux pas
encore prendre leur caméra
Ikaru dans les carreaux les carreaux il
a il a il a pas joué cette cette édition
IQ n'a pas joué l'édition
forcément
les deux sont là et les deux pour
l'instant pour continuer leur leur petit
chemin alors cavalier B4 ça c'est
bizarre généralement de de se défendre
en show clou en tout seul
il faudra avoir ce qui se passe avec
quelqu'un
pour aller venir clouer ce cavalier et
bien déjà je perds la cavalier ici donc
déjà c'est
c'est pas encore enfin c'est pas une
pièce graphique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici du coup
comment je défends ça
sûrement pas trop trop d'autres
possibilités tours c'est un maintenant
et les blancs la paire de fou le sang
qui peut être fragile un jour
en compensation de tout ça c'est
intéressant
c'est la partie
et là on l'imagine qu'il va reprendre
comme ça quand même
le frère de fille ou à 10h45
en frein de Fiero bah écoute moi j'ai
j'ai pas je sais pas ça moi alors
peut-être que c'est la peut-être que
c'est vrai mais je pense pas
vraiment qu'on commence par les
ça aurait du sens qu'on commence par les
petits c'est peut-être ça en fait
parce que là du coup si je regarde mon
truc malheureusement j'ai pas été
informé
voilà ça recommencé en fait
j'ai ça ouais j'ai les quatre en fait on
va commencer c'est ça on va commencer
par les par les divisions
division dépendante enfin vous savez la
poule des perdante si je vous montre un
petit peu le tableau la dernière fois
disons voulu faire c'est qu'on va
commencer par la poule déperlant et une
fois que les perdants ici
sera sera faite on passera la poule des
gagnants c'est bien ça en fait mais du
coup je n'avais pas été informé je viens
de le découvrir avec vous-même merci à
toi pôle en tout cas et salut prince
c'est ça salut à toi mais je vous
propose peut-être que ce sera mieux vous
me dites dites moi ce que vous voulez
est-ce que vous voulez suivre du coup
les les la poule des perdants de la
Division 1 ce qui veut dire que vous
avez absolument rien contre elianov et
vous vous avez lasavik contre
contre
la division 1 et 2
moi je fais ce que vous me dites en vrai
moi je préférerais les Français parce
que je trouve que c'est cool de suivre
les Français en plus il joue contre des
droits adversaires
c'est vraiment un cador dans ces dans
ces ces cadence et aussi combattraux
donc franchement
c'est une préférence mais vous me dites
vous me dites
le prince des fraises ouais je suis
assez d'accord en fait tout le monde qui
est contre contre lui mais
joue plus tard il joue direct enfin il
joue plus tard dès maintenant
ils vont jouer du coup après
après la poule des perdants c'est pour
ça que pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
Magnus c'est pas de Spirou il y a pas de
Caravana et donc en fait là j'avais un
peu je comprends mieux pourquoi tu
dormais
dans mon truc là j'en ai que 4
je comprends mieux pourquoi j'en avais
que quatre
OK
alors vous avez de sondage si vous
voulez vous pouvez vous pouvez voter le
sondage qui est sur twitch là qui a été
qui a été posé entre les Français et les
autres alors pour l'instant c'est plutôt
les Français qui gagnent
et je pense que c'est plus cool de voir
les Français aussi franchement
Laurent frais ciné qui qui a refusé de
venir commenter avec moi la préférée
venir jouer le tournoi donc on va aussi
quand même le soutenir je pense que
c'est quand même sympa
donc là on va française et ben écoute
les noirs on le centre les Blancs ont la
paire de fou
et le roi des roquets donc c'est quand
même deux inconvénients enfin
inconvénients c'est le roi des roquets
et le piment mais je la perte de fou en
on va dire en échange et j'ai plus moi
qui peut avancer il y a quelques
compensations mais je vous avoue que
j'aime bien
j'aime bien les Noirs quand même
c'est un peu seul je crois humer je
crois que c'est un petit peu seul
seul au monde la cadence c'est 15 + 3
c'est écrit en haut là je marque demi
finale parce que c'était la demi-finale
tout à l'heure mais là on est on est on
est en quoi là d'ailleurs si je veux si
je regarde deux secondes vous allez rien
voir je suis désolé si je vais voir le
comment je fais et pas un bracket là
pas de raquette ici
pas moyen d'avoir le
playing c'est pas ça
si j'ai le bracket ou pas je l'avais vu
tout à l'heure le braquage je sais pas
comment j'ai fait pour le voir
je vais regarder ailleurs c'est moi
pour voir en quelle
en quelle division est il est en quart
de finale des perdants
quart de finale déperdant notre ami
Laurent Freyssinet
alors que
alors qu'Etienne il est aussi encore des
finales c'est quart de finale
des gagnants
[Musique]
c'est en quart de finale des deux sont
encore de finale
des gagnants
dans les divisions 2 et 3
donc je vais vous changer je vais
remettre d'ailleurs sur l'Obs je vais
remettre ces quarts de finale
parce que
là vous allez pas comprendre sinon
je vais vous remettre quart de finale
en fait
et bien fait
on va arrêter comme ça
quart de finale je vous laisse hop
les chronos des joueurs mais ils sont
ils sont sur l'écran normalement tout
affiché normalement tu vois tout
et du coup tes meuf qui balance le petit
coup au 5 qui est un coup normal il
prend le centre de stopper la paire de
fou blanche commence qu'on pourrait
jouer ici à Simplon
sur H5 tu le cavalier je pense
intermédiaire qui peut être gênant
j'aime pas trop la pollution de Laurent
je vous l'avoue
je suis pas fan
est-ce que ça qui doit faire ça quand
même ok c'est pas c'est quoi juste sur
promet 4
ça me prend des 5 c'est interdit
c'était quoi le problème
moi que la jauge elle aime pas du tout
et j'essaie de voir ce qui se passe en
cavalier F4 on peut comprendre il y a ça
il y a ça qui arrive et en fait ça a
l'air très très dur si je bouge ma dame
il y aura fou échec voilà qui avait des
chèques et ça va commencer à faire pas
mal d'échecs
mais bon quand on est mal il faut
essayer de prendre comme ça et manger un
pion en plus un pion important peut-être
que ça aurait pu être une possibilité
d'armes B3 ça attaque le cavalier
non qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les Noirs
d'abord cavaler ses 6
dur à imager à l'origine non je pense
que tu peux l'imaginer parce que
ben ça structure souvent ça vient je
prends un F6 quand tu vois le sang comme
ça
tu peux la structure elle est ouais ok
c'est pas la première ouverture que tu
dirais mais
je pense que c'est quand même assez
logique
je pense que j'aurais deviner la
française tu m'avais demandé je t'aurais
dit française qualifiant
quasiment
avec cavaliers
qui avait les dessins
et prise hop elle aura la fin etc donc
ça c'est des positions que je connais en
plus mais
non en fait c'est pas la position que je
connais c'est la structure que je
reconnais un petit peu plus que
l'ouverture et quand même quelques
indices de dans la position qui nous
laisse deviner que ça apporte une
française c'est pas la position que je
connais même
donc ok position que j'aime pas trop
pour l'instant pour pour Laurent il lui
reste 4 minutes 55 contre 3 48 en face
donc Artémis il est quand même connu
pour réfléchir beaucoup donc c'est pas
trop pour l'instant grave de voir son
temps il est quand même plus bas de
celui de Laurent on fait un petit tour
chez chez
Étienne voir comment il s'en sort
Etienne
alors Étienne la position a continué à
être assez égal et écoutez la pollution
elle est compliquée parce que les Blancs
ont des pièces qui sont quand même
il y a pas mal avancé ce qui pourrait
être bien mais attention aux pièces pas
défendues là je vois ce cavalier qui est
pas défendue ça me fait peur des fois il
est tactique qui peuvent arriver quand
les pièces sont pas défendues vous voyez
et puis je vois aussi ce fou avec ce
cavalier là et tu es obligé un petit peu
de calculer des comme ca va le prendre
par exemple
prise à l'échec et ça il faut le
calculer après j'en sais rien du tout on
va peut-être ça marche ça marche pas là
j'ai vraiment fait au hasard
X4 été joué mais juste pour en dire que
on voit que les Noirs ont du potentiel
déjà très très vite ici
ce que je suis
il y a plus de pions blancs entre elles
et blanc ils sont fait miner le centre
donc ça c'est une proposition de nulle
implicite qui vient d'être d'être faite
à Étienne et qui changeait il a pas il a
pris la nul parce que souvent à ce
niveau là ça cherche les les répétitions
regardez foulard je viens tu reviens tu
reviens je reviens et on s'amuse comme
ça jusqu'au bout de la nuit et en fait
ici Étienne il a répété une fois puis il
est venu en C4 pour améliorer la
position ce qui veut dire que
il joue peut-être le gars et donc dans
cette deuxième division et ben les
matchs se jouent en deux parties
donc un particulier avec les noirs et à
l'essuie de partir si on est encore en
réalité il y aura un mag et donc il faut
bien profiter de la couleur tu as les
blancs il faut essayer de mettre un peu
la pression avec les Blancs
mais c'est une très bonne ouverture la
française fout des trois mais c'est pas
mon
type de structure attention Étienne
marlou qui va menacer un petit matin
j'ai 7 c'est bon ça marche
il peut toujours rêver
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe sur fouet 5
attaque là et là il y a un problème ou
quoi
là
je suis débile ou quoi
la chose elle aime pas du tout
s'il prend
une belle
et si il prend un S7 bah je prends la
intermédiaire et après je prends
voilà je prends là j'arrive pas à la
flèche voilà donc ok ta mère
il va échanger probablement les dames
qui avaient des fois en plus donc il y a
pas de problème sur F2 après on prend la
position mais je dirais que la position
blanche est quand même un peu plus
facile à jouer parce que les pièces sont
un peu plus actives mais ça reste quand
même assez assez égalité tout ça
donc Étienne qui fait pour l'instant de
partie très solide
on va venir rapidement sur sur Laurent
Laurent qui qui se bat donc on s'est
arrêté à Dame B3 il y a eu A5 pour
défendre les cavaliers
et sur A5 on a eu le coup H5 finalement
jouer cavalue 7 et moi j'ai un donc il
veut j'imagine bien ranger le roi pour
faire sortir la tour et sur D4 il y a eu
cavalier H4
éventuellement plus tard
sur diagonale et sur T4 cavaliers H4
OK
donc j'imagine qu'il vaut aussi des
coups comme dame G3 peut-être comme ça
Dame des cinq pour échanger là mais dans
ma 3 OK
ça me dépasse un peu c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour
salut magret
tout droit avec les jouets
écoutez Laurent qui se barre à la
position elle est très très difficile
pour les blancs il y a un pion de moi il
y a un centre pour les Noirs mais il y a
quand même un roi un roi noir
assez faible au centre quand même mais
prends soin de dur à attendre
si jamais j'arrivais un jour à faire du
Fou au
4e par ici par exemple peut-être que sur
15 manches je pourrais faire mal
c'est compliqué
c'est
pas ouvert sa fenêtre
pourquoi il a pas ouvert sa fenêtre
bonne question
moi je pensais pour pouvoir avoir une un
passage pour la dame je pense tout à
l'heure mais il a pas fait donc je ne
sais pas il y a aussi la case F5 que tu
peux viser plus tard mais pour l'instant
c'est un peu dur d'y accéder donc je
pense que c'était plutôt sur le long
terme ramener le fou et passer par là
ok donc Laurent qui récupère son pion et
tout reprend à deux était pas possible à
cause de fou E6 échec et récupère la
tour donc
toujours en problème et sur A3 je perds
le petit pion en 3 donc je peux pas le
défendre
apparemment j'avais pas vu que j'étais
encore sur le sur le rings de
Magnus excuse-moi j'avais j'étais un
petit peu
hors sujet là F4 peut-être ouvrir un peu
la position essayer de
d'ouvrir les tours ouvrir le jeu
très chaud j'aime pas du tout la
position de Laurent quand même il
souffre beaucoup la tour à champ qui
joue pas le roi qui est en finale mais
qui bloque la tour Caballé au bord qui
joue pas le pion qui est faible en a
deux je pense ça va être dur pour pour
le rang ici et Étienne comment il est
Étienne Étienne qui sa partie donc il y
a eu une chance de dames comme on
l'avait dit il y a eu fou ces trois et
cavalier C5 a été joué et pas mal
d'échanges qu'elle va laisser 3 et la
position qui capte quand même assez
assez équilibré
à sac
mais je suis pas sûr de résultat
le foot si je prends qu'elle va les
prendre là ça a l'air assez assez
équilibré je pense qu'on va plutôt
retourner sur la partie de Laurent c'est
la partie je pense qui est le plus
compliqué il a joué F4 Laurent un jeu
mon coup ça c'est pas c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour lui mais
en plus le groupe ozone
en roumain et du coup je pense que je
pense que Yumi doit bien connaître cette
chanson
salut
Théodore c'est moi
c'est ça il y a pas filou ça joue après
Fiero ça joue après
ça joue un petit peu après dans environ
une heure
cavaler des cinq est-ce que c'est le
moment de jouer un petit fou C4
tapez un petit peu sur la sur la
diagonale et tous les vis-à-vis
oui c'est du romain ouais
en plus on voit le temps il y a plus de
temps pour un terminal donc ça 15 + 3
donc il est pas encore fichu autant mais
on peut mettre la pression la Tour
Eiffel qui peut être pas mal ici il y a
eu trop bien et si il changeait MP4 en
l'air c'est intéressant pour bien la
chose n'aime pas du tout moi j'aimais
bien je trouvais ça bien pour G4
cavalier
dedans attention peut-être G3 va être
obligé
j'ai trois
quasi obligatoire
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on joue après
aussi le fou
mais bon ça a l'air quand même de
s'annuler pas mal ça va les prendre je
prends là
tu prends là je prends là
fou F3 ok encore mieux ce qui fait
manger ici d'accord
deux pions chacun deux pièces chacun
faut juste faire attention à la part de
G3 et la position qui peut être
proche de l'égalité
mais ça reste quand même pas évident
pour
pour les blancs
qui avaient le 5 avalé prend des 7
il y a aussi ça en l'air derrière c'est
extrêmement compliqué là tu dois rester
sur la 5e rangée pour empêcher les
échecs ici
donc là ça va ça va ça va nul prise
et ça va faire nul pour pour Laurent et
c'est franchement une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'il était il était pas bien
toute la partie
archéienne et Ben et ben il a toujours
sa pollution
sa position solide Etienne je pense
qu'il est aussi bien parti pour faire
annuler à son tour la belle défense de
la part de de Laurent très très belle
défense
Laurent qui aura droit à une autre
partie pour essayer de se qualifier pour
les demi-finales de la deuxième division
firu il a pas commencé encore
il commence dans dans environ une
demi-heure une heure
ce qui se passe quand la division 1
c'était à la base c'est ce qu'on suivait
mais comme on préfère suivre la division
2 et 3 avec Etienne Bacro et Laurent
Freyssinet
et ben on va plutôt faire ça et après on
ira dans la première division
j'ai pas d'horé en fait ça joue quand ça
finit en fait quand la deuxième division
enfin quand la première division finit
croyez perdants finissent et ben les
gagnants rentrent en chêne
et la deuxième division on a on a
lasavik qui joue contre
tamatabey donc c'est un peu moins
excitant qu'un petit backi ma médiocre
quand même et on a aussi
moins excitant aussi qu'un
artemief Freyssinet en tout cas je pense
que les Français quand même on est quand
même on est quand même là pour les
soutenir
et si on a 45 filles roux quoi je
comprends que on va quand même suivre
plutôt car c'est où mais là il joue plus
tard donc
en comparaison je préfère suivre les
Français que suivre que suivre tavate
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas trop en
plus
ils sont plus moins fort que
les autres
ça peut tourner un peu mais bon il y a
pas grand chose à faire j'ai
l'impression je dirais que les noirs
sont un peu mieux quand même parce que
la structure est plus solide et en plus
les cavaliers sont un petit peu embêtant
quand même
un peu embêtant
je pense que voilà tenir quand même je
pense que tenir
mais les noirs sont un tout petit peu
mieux pas
sur il m'a donné
de jouer c'est bien ça
c'est bien ça quelle est ici donc avec
les deux on défend le pion H4 peut-être
des 5 va être le couple tout est changé
et faire mieux direct
elle va aller prendre qu'elle va les
prendre
donc c'est un petit peu bizarre quand
même parce que nous fait ma médiérophe
il va jouer à H4
mais j'ai l'impression
que ça fait nulle direct non prise on
apprend et là il y a un trébuchet qui
peut arriver là enfin attention
il y a un trébuchet qui peut arriver
c'est finir elle est connue elle est
nulle à cause de l'opposition et ça va
jouer jusqu'au jusqu'au pattes
ça va jusqu'au pâtes
voilà jusqu'au patte donc cette finale
assez intéressante ça fait nul direct
mais regardez bien en fait attention je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'entre vous qui
voudraient aller manger le pion inverse
mais attention sur ça j'aurai le coup
roi Alcat qui vient défendre mon pion et
attaquer le tien et là ici la position
des Noirs serait perdu parce qu'après
roi rouge où tu veux bah je prends et
j'ai droit devant le pion et
en plus tu as pas toi l'opposition donc
là du coup je vais gagner je montre mon
roi et je pousse mon pion et je vais
gagner c'est facile et la vente café
il se dit je sais que tu vas manger mon
pion mais je m'en fous je me mets ici et
quand tu manges le pion je la mettrai
ici en en position
très facile
à faire nul avec les Noirs ici il faut
juste prendre la position et ne pas
permettre au roi noir de gagner
l'opposition d'accord je bouge mon roi
je garde le position et c'est un gagnant
très F4 voilà hop on recule toujours
derrière pourquoi parce que quand je
monte mon roi il faut que j'arrive à
faire opposition directement avec les
mains vous imaginez que si jamais je
reculez comme ça avec le roi et ben
c'était blanc qui prend opposition c'est
bon alors que nous ce qu'on veut c'est
nous mettre nous-mêmes en face du roi
adverse donc je peux pas aller en
diagonale en recette parce qu'il
prendrait l'opposition
et donc roi F7 important on voit ici et
roi E7 opposition
F6 voilà voilà et encore une fois on va
ici regarder si on va sur un côté ici
regardez bien les blancs prennent la
position et en plus après F7 et ben je
vais pas pouvoir empêcher la promotion
du pion ce qui veut dire que c'est
vraiment important alors que les forces
tout droit pour garder l'opposition dès
que je viens là il y a position ici et
si je vis un petit côté là il y a
opposition de ce côté là et ça fera nul
tout le temps
voilà et quand tu viens là et ben c'est
pâtes comme dans la partie
ok donc en tout cas est une Bacro qui
freiner qui a neutralisé aussi
artemière donc de gros matchs on va
quand même revenir à au parti des
intéressés dans
dans la première division ça joue encore
par contre là je peux vous mettre les
[Musique]
pour mettre les parties avec les caméras
vous avez tout donc on n'a pas de
caméras des divisions 2 et 3
malheureusement mais dans la division 1
gagnant et perdant on a les caméras
donc on va pouvoir suivre celle là avant
que ça reprenne 3 à 4 5 6 3 4 5 6 donc
c'est une finale
assez égale où les blancs sont quand
même mieux pourquoi parce que j'ai une
majorité au centre vous voyez j'ai
quatre pions contre 3
et si un jour et
donc ici les dents sont un petit peu
mieux le talent un peu moins
parce que si jamais ils arrivent à
pousser un jour F4 et ben j'aurais
vraiment cette majorité qui pourrait
avancer et être un pion passé un jour
qui pourrait avancer mais pour l'instant
c'est difficile parce que sur F4 il y a
prise et j'ai un problème sur le pion de
4 il sera prise deux fois par les pièces
noires
après il y a aussi un monde où je peux
faire tout un chat et H5 essayer de
passer par là-bas avec mon pion et Mato
mais pas évidemment en tout cas faut que
le reposer problème sur le pion E5
je pense que la position blanche est
intéressante gagnante pas sûr mais en
tout cas il y a moyen de pousser un peu
du côté de tabac tabeuil avec
avec les Blancs
beaucoup de déco
écoute je ne sais pas est-ce que est-ce
que dans le chat
c'est la même pour vous ou pas parce que
chez moi je l'entends rien et j'ai pas
du tout eu de j'ai pas du tout eu de
problème depuis le début du stream
depuis hier à ce niveau là donc
non je crois que ça donne chez toi kung
fu
je crois que tes enceintes sont pas
forcément très bonnes du coup si c'est
toi le problème parce que apparemment
chez les autres ça marche plutôt bien
donc H5 a été joué donc l'idée que
j'avais évoqué tout à l'heure surpuis on
prend on fera tour à chat on va
récupérer le pion et la colonne ouverte
ça c'est cool maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je peux manger ici et ramener la
tour après en H1 tu peux directement
faire un tour à champ ou même peut-être
même faire H6 des fois ce petit pion
peut devenir un peu faible mais je sais
j'aime pas trop parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'un jour j'arriverai à aller
manger le plan à H7 alors il y a eu tout
romain déjà prise et la manger notre
histoire
en fait avec toi ce qu'il a fait ici
j'aurais pu ici à la place de faire pour
échec il aurait pu la reprise et tout
machin pour rentrer ici mais là d'abord
attiré le roi noir sur la case de 7
pour
quand je fais ton machin là c'est échec
sur H7 et en plus j'empêche ton recettes
des morts donc intéressant en tout cas
ce qu'il a fait avec les Blancs c'est la
partie tout ça et je pense qu'il y a
moyen qui mette la pression c'est un peu
faible si j'en mange un des deux c'est
fini
et bon ben peut-être tourgé vite essayer
un jour de faire F4 dans le sens encore
difficile de faire F4 mais sur le long
terme ça passe une possibilité
et en tout cas des Blancs ont une belle
pollution de travail je pense que
franchement
il peut pousser un peu
il a zéro risque de perdre en plus donc
c'est cool
ok donc tourage suite a été joué
ouvrir l'autre partie voir Abdou contre
Eliano on a cette partie aussi
et donc elle est neuve qui a des blancs
je vais vous mettre les
caméras aussi des joueurs Pavel Eliano
contre
qui a perdu hier contre qui ont perdu
respectivement contre so Wesley et
contre les raisins Firuza
alors c'est une position quand même qui
est intéressante pour les blancs il y a
un pion passé mais attention ce pion qui
peut être aussi des fois
qui peut devenir faible
en prise prise
faire attention qu'un instrument un
petit pion qui peut un jour devenir une
cible
et peut-être que je peux réussir ça
c'est de fou manger le pion
dessert ça peut être ça peut vite
tourner donc les blancs qui ont l'air
pas mal mais au final attention et sur
des 6 5 ça qui veut
des sismes ça pourrait pas mal pour les
blancs c'est noir font E5 maintenant on
garde ce petit pion faible et je crois
que tout ce qui va tomber là
juste le retour pour manger des sets qui
a l'air assez intéressant ici
hop
donc
et là il a carrément donné le pion et
donc ils sont le pion il était quand
même très faible donc il est pas plus en
accroché prise tout reprend cette finale
là alors est-ce qu'elle va gagner ou pas
c'est sûr qu'elle perdra pour les Noirs
donc le noir on a la possibilité de
pouvoir de pouvoir pousser sans avoir
une seule chance de perdre c'est plutôt
cool de la gagner c'est quand même
3 pour limiter les gages du cavalier
il y a un pion de plus certes mais
beaucoup de pions
et en plus je pourrais toujours à la fin
ça suffit un fou sur un pion
je pense qu'il y a de bonnes chances de
nulle quand même pour elianov mais plus
de temps on a pendule et Abdou qui est
très très qui en plus
hyper tricky plein de temps à la pendule
dans une position qui
quand même a l'air d'être nul en tout
cas d'ailleurs de pouvoir tenir la nul
c'est pas du tout clair qu'ici on va
réussir à la tenir celle-là
même si elle a quand même cette position
quand même
alors G4 pour échanger un petit peu les
pions
qui se passe quoi G4 F4 je suis pas sûr
de vouloir de vouloir laisser les Noirs
pousser en fait les pions
je sais pas comment on la comment on la
joue celle là
pour qu'elle c'est sûr qu'on va pas du
tout
échanger les pièces vous imaginez si je
mangeais le pion viendrait ici et serait
passé mais ça n'a pas du tout envie
de ça
ils vont attendre
ils vont attendre que les Noirs fassent
quelque chose dès qu'il y a un plan qui
avance je mange parce que moyen de pions
plus les chances de faire mieux
la cadence c'est 15 + 3 ça écrit en haut
on va revenir du coup
c'est le ciel bleu 15 + 3
on tourne on tourne on tourne on tourne
9 secondes à la pendule
pour les blancs
j'ai 5 alors là il faut manger sans
réfléchir et on va revenir avec le foot
peut-être en C2 en C6 mais il faut
attendre il faut attendre il y a pas
grand chose
à faire il faut que je vide par contre
il y a plus de temps la pendu en plus la
position est quand même assez facile à
jouer
facile dans le sens que
il met le fou ici et puis il attend quoi
donc s'il tombe c'est quand c'est
dommage et là comment on compte nos
cavaliers 4
je ferai roi j'ai deux probablement
pas perdre l'option quand même et on
peut pas trop quand même changer les
pièces je vous rappelle qu'on a un pion
de moi on garde des pièces absolument
si j'arrive à échanger un pion et ben
mon fou pourra venir manger le deuxième
pion
le 4 roi G2 obligé
et les noirs qui vont essayer de passer
mais à chaque fois ce fou ici
problématique alors si je mange et
fourchettes je récupérerai le full à eau
je peux pas manger on attend
et on va continuer à attendre ce roi F3
et ben je mange là puis là
pas partir de ça donc on continue
fouet
assez nul cette position Roger 2 on
attend
on voit ici on attend
de plein de Manon de plein de manières
tu bouges le roi tu bouges le flou tu
fais ce que tu veux
ce qui va revenir en dessert
je vois vraiment pas comment les noirs
peuvent ici être position ça m'a l'air
tellement facile de faire mieux
échec on revient que le fou
on revient que le roi
et
[Musique]
on attend moi le problème des Noirs
c'est qu'ils peuvent pas
partir avec Laura quoi c'est toujours
sans prise donc j'ai toujours lui ou lui
qui doit rester en contact de pion donc
du coup j'ai pas le temps de vraiment
faire un truc avec avec les pièces c'est
très compliqué de sortir de ça
[Musique]
et on tourne on tourne autour on tourne
allez donne le pion mais si le moment
j'ai encore la fourchette
macro il joue il vient de faire nul dans
certains parties on va voir après la
deuxième
sur un pion bah tu manges mais après
j'arriverai j'arriverai à te manger des
pions donc ça fera nul de toute façon
piège de gros plus mais ok tu tentes
[Musique]
tu tentes maintenant c'est nul là il
faut il faut signer
il faut signer et j'ai l'impression
quand même que
Abdou l'air de le savoir
a l'air de le savoir que ça va faire
mieux mais il a raison de de la vraiment
raison de la jouer avec les Noirs parce
que c'est du Blitz et en tournant et ben
on peut un petit peu essayer de rendre
l'adversaire un peu ma boule
jusqu'à le faire tilter quoi
ça arrive souvent genre de choses mais
la position ici est quand même tellement
facile à jouer pour le blanc que je vois
pas comment il peut il peut arnaquer
une piscine pourquoi pas
il y a vraiment beaucoup de temps la
pendu même 25 secondes c'est largement
assez pour pour aller blanc
c'est largement assez
[Musique]
c'est nul facile dans les deux cas
et je suis assez d'accord avec je pense
que c'est plus facile de gagner celle-là
que de gagner celle-là parce que les
pions sont pas assez avancés de toute
façon les deux
les deux possibilités sont nuls très
très facilement
et après tu fais quoi
tu fais F3 bah je mettrai un fou ici et
je sacrifierai quoi
qu'en fait tu pourras jamais rien faire
une chance ouais bon de toute façon
c'est facile alors firou il va jouer
quand ce match là sera terminé donc ce
match là c'est c'est la première partie
du match donc il y en aura il y aura
deux parties en 15 + 3 et en cas
d'égalité il y aura un départage à la
mangue et donc qui sera qui sera
[Musique]
qui sera qui sera joué et une fois que
le match sera terminé et ben Magnus Firo
Kawana
et
Esso et ben selon à nous pour ce petit
match donc voici
tu peux pas
[Musique]
on peut rien faire
plus rien faire
ici 8 on va revenir cavaler les 6 ou
voilà et on va encore une fois
quasiment trois fois la même position je
crois
comme un coup en tout cas qui a pas eu
de prise de pions
les Noirs ont fait J4
il est noir en fait G4 c'était quand
c'était au 46e
[Musique]
automatiquement
prise ni mouvement de pion
donc c'est au 96 normalement le coup je
pense fort en 90ème coup de franchir le
90e donc faut pas donner de pièces
encore cinq coups à tenir tabel
full
a complètement fini
force un peu bah
il peut pas trop forcer un vrai il y a
pas grand chose on voit que les joueurs
les joueurs ont terminé je vous rappelle
qu'il y a une minute de décalage entre
eux et nous
donc
peut-être que ça va encore un peu
peut-être pas on sait pas
mais il y a un décalage ça continue un
peu alors que eux ils ont terminé vous
voyez bien sur la caméra les joueurs ont
fini
96 ça va faire ça à faire nul 94
encore deux normalement
le prochain coup
ça va être signé automatiquement
parce que ça fait 96 voilà j'avais bien
compté donc ça fait nul direct 96e
partie du petit match alors je vais vous
montrer un petit peu le tableau pour
ceux qui sera arrivé en retard donc on a
ici le 45 Karo Alain et le saut firouza
qui va jouer une fois que la poule des
perdants en bas aura terminé alors qu'en
dessous on voit que tabac Tabei et ben
il mène 1-0 entre raservic parti on l'a
pas suivi en entier ça veut dire que
tabathalie il a réussi à transformer
cette finale on va en parler de cette
finale on disait que c'était c'était
intéressant et qui peut peut-être là la
poussée on verra comment il a gagné
et les neufs Abdou ça va c'est nul donc
on va voir la partie rapidos pour voir
comment
comment est-ce qu'il a réussi à la
passer donc on s'est arrêté ici et en
fait ici il a joué
alors je vais un peu vite pour voir un
petit peu tout ça
apparemment
à 4
et du coup il a ses options peut-être
plus tard qui va être
un problème dans la position donc là
c'est le niveau supérieur quand même se
rendre compte un petit peu de ses
petites subtilités
tricote un petit peu avec les Blancs il
tourne il tourne il tourne il passe le
roi et il va réussir à jouer F4
maintenant qu'il y a plus le fou pour
prendre le pion le cadre voyez il pousse
l'option F4 prise en dessous de 5 on
bouge le roi et maintenant il y a tout
quittons un petit peu là on a la foutu
le reposée deux pions passer protégés ça
c'est terminé assez facile pour le coup
écoutez qui prend une belle option dans
ces dans ces quarts de finale de la
poule des perdants et qui va jouer enfin
il y a encore une partie mais que si il
perd pas la prochaine partie et ben il
va jouer contre
il y aura contre le gagnant de
Rohff et elof alors je vais voir comment
ce temps là si dans la poule 2 et 3
Laurent Frayssinet
et Bacro joue encore et je crois que
c'est le cas
on va sur un petit peu c'est parti si
vous le voulez bien
où sont-ils
attendez je vais faire par partie
par partie
non c'est pas ça
[Musique]
c'est pas la partie je n'ai pas encore
la partie en fait ça les mystères tesoa
merci à toi bienvenue à toi
je te dis merci
et par contre et ça joue
à partir
je peux vous mettre si vous voulez le
côté noir
on va les rattraper rapidement
donc quand mesdames acceptées
éventuellement et lancer l'attaque sur
le roi
E5 a été joué H5
que se passe-t-il sur cavalier prend un
j'imagine que vous posez la même
question que moi
que se passe-t-il si je joue cavalier E5
la jauge n'aime pas ça
donc ça doit être ça
il y a eu trois tours de 6
les Scorpions ici
ce pion en prise ce pion en prise et
plein de problèmes si je bouge mon
cavalier cette fois-ci cavaler sera
possible parce que je serais cloué
j'aurais pas qu'elle va les prendre 5
intéressantes ici on voit qu'il y a un
gros gros décalage de temps on voit
Étienne qui lui reste moins d'une minute
contre 8 minutes chez la media off ça
sent très très mauvais pour le joueur
français ici si tu es une personne
partie bah il sera éliminé de la poule
des gagnants donc il aura un joker
une de ces vies
on a deux vies
c'est un peu chaud pour rester là
effectivement
c'est un peu chaud il y a des coups qui
sont joués mais moi je les vois pas
pourquoi prise prise c'est la partie
et il y a plus de temps pour Étienne
c'est très dur il y a ça en prise sans
prise il y a aussi un clouage qui pour
arriver sur la colonne des
et tout ça c'est extrêmement dur à gérer
je pense qu'il va devoir perdre un pion
ça te donne
au moins un pion en fait
une fourchette canon attention
pas non plus elle est trop vite
dame D1 qui est bien si Caval et bout
j'ai pas je prends je prends 5 c'est la
partie
trop dur pour pour être ici
attaque le cavalier en dessert et là je
vais pouvoir manger en 5
de la pièce que je veux
et ça a l'air dur ici déjà pour Étienne
j'ai pas assez de j'ai rien là-haut je
peux pas rentrer même ça
c'est pas marcher genre de chose quoi
probablement
là j'ai plein de trucs là intéressant
j'ai la tour qui fait bouger
même ça ça a l'air ça a l'air c'est
perdu c'est perdu deux pions de moi plus
l'attaque Étienne qui
qui va pas la tenir celle-là
ce serait très étonnant qu'il arrive à
la tenir
donc
là juste au pire des cas échange des
dames n'est pas mauvais depuis en plus
mais attention quand même si je prends
la parole des bouges ma tour il y a
toujours ton là qui a un petit peu
gênant ça doit gagner encore pour
les Noirs mais attention quand même que
la tour elle peut être active
un tout petit peu attention et ça la
partie
c'est la partie qui a la diète tour à 6
ou tour c'est 7
c'est pas le micro-ondes du tout c'était
mon ventilateur que je viens de mettre
en marche aux ralenti l'autre qui est
silencieux à côté de moi et vu qu'il
fait très très chaud et que j'ai la clim
chez moi mais la clim n'arrive pas
jusque là où je suis du coup il fait un
peu chaud donc je mets je mets le
ventilo
c'est pas le micro-ondes je mange pas je
mange pas devant vous
pas très bon là pour le coup salut je
vais commencer des échecs qui tient six
mois je voulais savoir c'était possible
ultime d'un club Pour progresser ou bien
c'est trop tard à 20 ans ben écoute je
pense que le la meilleure chose pour toi
à faire c'est inscrire dans un club
donc je pense que c'est vraiment motivé
qui va vraiment tu veux le faire va dans
un club en plus ça la rentrée il y a
beaucoup de clubs qui ont qui ont
proposé des cours donc même si tu es
débutant il y a pas de souci il y a
vraiment des cours par niveau et des
cours débutants
donc si tu veux tu peux me dire où tu
habites quelle ville et je peux t'aider
si tu veux peut-être que je peux te dire
je peux te t'éguiller un petit peu vers
certains clubs que je connais qui peut
être sympa ça dépend où tu es je connais
pas tout non plus mais j'en connais
quand même pas mal
sympa j'aime bien j'aime bien
pour me créer ce petit pion passé
je pense que tout est bien
et il va vouloir être le cavalier
là-haut mais bon
c'est un peu désespéré
il va manger le Caballé je pense
prochain coup c'est tout reprendre le 5
qui est très mauvais par par ma mère
boom boom boom et le pion il est
inarrêtable
et ça va être abondant
ou non il y a pas il y a pas de dames
folle ça aurait été marrant Kingdom
folle Etienne qui est noir qui est
complètement buggé avec son entourageant
il veut un patte mais il n'y a pas de
pattes en fait
il y a pas de pâte
le Val d'Oise ou le bas c'est ça c'est
un coin ou malheureusement je connais
pas trop trop
[Musique]
alors
là je suis plus le tout dessus je
connais bien
sacrément je regarde beaucoup de vidéos
progressives sur Paris mais je suis sûr
que je vais trouver pas mal de clubs à
Paris Paris il y a de quoi faire c'est
vraiment c'est la capitale de la France
évidemment c'est très grand Paris il y a
beaucoup de clubs possibles donc ouais
ok donc
Étienne qui a perdu donc elle tienne qui
qui était éliminé de cette poule par
contre Laurent Laurent était comme ça
voilà j'ai récupéré la partie de la
partie de Laurent Laurent allée noir on
va essayer de tourner les chéquier
et donc la jauge qui aime bien les
blancs parce qu'il y a une petite
tactique avec fupron tourpran Tourcoing
et Tourcoing ici avec un pion de plus
pour
pour les blancs mais les fenêtres de
tour vous savez que c'est jamais si
évident ça a plus certes mais c'est pas
sûr encore que ça va gagner alors
j'aimerais bien rapidement et c'est de
refaire juste rattraper un petit peu le
temps depuis le début
et artimus qui aime bien cette fiche
schéma comme ça là
OK
donc c'est la partie c'était ça ok pour
des vies tu prends
il a raté ça
et Laurent qui a la pendule 8 minutes
contre 3 30
et il a une finale où il est clairement
moins bien il y a un pion moi
mais
peut-être tenable j'y crois pas trop
avoir
si il arrive s'il arrive à la à la tenir
cette cette finale
quand je vois
moi
la moyenne on va dire vous savez de
les pourcentages de bons coups des
blancs et des noirs et vous me croirez
pas si je vous dis que les blancs sont à
99,9 % de précision pour l'instant dans
cette partie
et je vous promets que c'est le cas
99,9 après 23 pouces et ses monstrueux
tu reprends les deux maintenant on va
appeler la technique de artemiev voir un
petit peu comment il s'en sort au niveau
de la technique
[Musique]
petit t-shirt
toute sa vie donc ça c'est facile pour
lui
moi je crois une fois j'ai fait 96
quelque chose comme moi j'ai fait ça
j'ai fait 100 fois
je fais 100
bah c'est quand tu joues la théorie et
que ton anniversaire il fait genre il
faut de souris ou quoi et qu'il
abandonne au bout de cinq coups
j'ai fait les bons coups à chaque fois
mais sinon tu arrives à me faire ça
après des fois tu peux voir des gros des
gros scores quand tu connais vraiment
bien la position que tu as beaucoup joué
moi plein de fois je fais 99 ça m'arrive
plein de fois
mais c'est vraiment des positions
particulières quand même quand tu
réussites vraiment la théorie très loin
ou tu as travaillé un truc à la maison
donc à 5 c'est un mauvais coup
apparemment de la part de Laurent alors
pourquoi alors généralement c'est vrai
que on touche pas trop au pion c'est
final là mais j'imagine que ce qu'il
veut c'est essayer d'aller peut-être
échanger
les pions comme ça
vous savez il a un pion noir
dans la fin du tour et généralement plus
les pions sont échangés plus leur a de
chance de faire nul
donc peut-être que l'idée de faire
tour là en train de faire à 5 c'est de
faire après un truc comme ça quoi
pour échanger les pions et ça tient nul
mais bon c'est pas évident et c'est
facile de critiquer quand nous on a des
on a des des petits signes comme ça on a
on a la jauge c'est facile pour nous
critiquer
ramener un peu les pièces mais les Noirs
vont vraiment essayer d'échanger les
pièces il y a eu le tour des trois qui
empêchent Roy F3 et probablement à 4
prochaines
un peu les deux petits pions qui sont à
deux et à 4 possibilités
hier mais voilà j'aime c'est pas quelque
chose c'est pas quelque chose que je
que je vise donc je suis assez cool avec
ça donc t'inquiète pas tout va bien mon
avis
toujours des scores de merde parce que
si tu fais un dès le début c'est clair
que c'est pas ta faveur ça c'est clair
[Musique]
des quatre cinq ou quatre des cinq merci
ciel bleu c'est les belles ouvertures
d'avoir toujours en tout cas dans le
début de très très mauvais mauvaise
score de la moins qu'on joue moi je la
file avec les noirs et quand je vois
premier coup D6 l'ordinateur il me dit
que c'est que c'est pas un coup très bon
quoi c'est mon premier coup quoi en plus
qui est pas étudié quand
les connaisseurs savent mais me mettre
que c'est un coup qui est pas bon dès le
premier coup ça va quand même
et stock fish il est un peu dur
peut-être précision
mais pas content quand on voit quand on
voit 4 dessins
donc souvent c'est ça quand on a des
ouvertures un peu bizarre
ok la tour aller active ici n'a tourne
planche encore plus active donc là vous
verrez pas un échange de pions massifs
vous ne verrez pas ça
ce qui va se passer je pense c'est que
les blancs vont essayer de ramener de
ramener leurs rois donc je sais pas
comment ils vont faire un H4
défendre le pion là montant un peu le
roi et faire un truc comme ça donc tour
à trois on peut avoir un H4 je pense que
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment l'idée
l'idée de d'artemief en tout cas pousser
les pions passer droit pendant que je
garde la pression sur le pion V6
et que
j'active quoi
il a fait sonore pour pour stocker
avec maman je crois que c'est
la Tour Eiffel
oui par le plan c'est ça de toute façon
elle est noir qu'on peut empêché le plan
que nous a montré HK to f43 je crois
avoir G4 les Noirs pourront pas
l'empêcher de toute façon donc peu
importe la manière mais je vois trop
pousser les pions non plus
Détroit E5 cavalier 2 ça c'était
c'est comment il s'appelle je vois pas
qu'il avait joué je crois que il a
d'ailleurs battu Etienne Bacro avec ça
avec E40
avec les Blancs
donc j'ai 6
qu'il attend je pense que le roi F7 il
joue G4 il va jouer F3 F3 est monté
droit comme ça
en tout cas les blancs et même si la
fondue ils ont une mite à la pendule ben
ça reste facile à je peux ils ont pas de
grandes décisions à prendre
donc le fait d'avoir à l'avance autant
c'est pas non plus quelque chose
de si grave en fait j'ai cinq est un
coup qui en est bloqué un petit peu le
roi
F3
voilà G5 rang G4 un truc comme ça
avoir comment comment il va passer ça
et Laurent Freyssinet qui est en train
essayer de tenir sa finale contrat
donc il y a une nulle à la première et
si tient celle-là bah il y aura un
départage s'il la perd ben sera éliminé
malheureusement
le 4 c'est 6 cavaler C3 D5
2 4 le 4 x 2 F6
sur la même
OK
il s'est passé quoi
les gars c'est un ami il mérite pas
d'être time out
merci j'espère que
ok tu mérites un peu quand même tu
mérites un peu
tu mérites un petit peu
H5 arrache 5 peut-être j'ai 5
et ramener le roi par là manger ici
peut-être faire échec ramener le roi et
ramener le roi ici ça alors quand même
très très dur pour pour l'orange je
pense qu'il va la perdre celle-là
je pense que ça va être dur celle-là
Laurent qui souffre
j'ai pas trop le choix et là en fait le
problème c'est que les Noirs ils peuvent
pas bouger quoi je peux même pas ramener
le roi ici on a toujours la source qui
prend la sur échec
donc
il va faire roi là parce qu'il n'a pas
l'autre coup voilà ou tour là quoi enfin
il a pas de quoi en fait
au lieu de 4
il est extrêmement bon
artémis est une incroyable
donc là en fait il va juste monter le
droit
et il prendra la au bon moment
là
plus remonter ici
et quand on va partira je pourrai aller
manger
avec le roi et puis
je vais charger notre ami Laurent
comment il a pu croire gagner une finale
en fait il avait un pion du moins en
début de la finale
et il a essayé la défendre mais en face
c'est quand même très solide
enfin c'est très solide
de fraise mais là il s'est mis au fond
en face c'est technique c'est c'est
classique irréprochable
je peux jamais manger en fait enfin je
faisais monter la course de la prise sur
échec F4 F5 va être une possibilité
voilà
qui pourrait être pas mal
avec le C1 il le sait il le sait Laurent
son retour je pense que ça
il fait ça
parce que j'aurais pu faire un truc du
style
dans la prise des tours échec essayer de
gratter celui-là
il y avait quoi il y a eu trois dessins
même si je fais ça ça c'est gagné facile
en fait
c'est trop facile à jouer
beaucoup trop facile à jouer pour la tu
peux jouer mais il prend il va juste il
va pousser le pion
et j'espère du coup
d'ailleurs peut-être même je peux faire
ça d'ailleurs
voilà l'arbitre
c'est juste perdu c'est juste perdu
et il continue à pousser le pion bah
ouais si tu prends là regardez comment
c'est mignon tu prends je fais ça
bon j'arrive pas à le faire ça joue trop
vite
tac tac ça va être un bonbon
prochain coup de la part de Laurent
c'est Laurent freestyle avec les Blancs
contre Artemia avec les noirs et
s'abandon Sophie
et ici en fait si jamais il avait
mangé depuis un F4 il y aurait eu à 6
pour là à 7 et prochain coup échec suivi
de dames et tu ne peux pas du tout
empêcher la promotion de Madame et ma
tour ira manger les pions qui manquent
donc malheureusement bon on a perdu nos
deux Français on a perdu Laurent
freestyle on a perdu Macron lors de ces
deux étapes et on va revenir du coup
dans ces matchs avec
abusottarov contre contre elianov
[Musique]
et on a aussi
lasavik contre tabac d'abeille et
ensuite une fois que c'est deux matchs
là seront terminés et ben on passera à
la poule des gagnants avec nos deux
matchs très intéressants on a Magnus
Carlson qui joue contre Carola et on
aura aussi so Wesley contre
deux matchs très très intéressant qu'on
va suivre juste après
donc ça c'est une espagnole
systématique
et à une nulle dans la première partie
donc si le meilleur résultat décisif
dans cette partie là
et ben ça sera
le gagnant de la partie qui se
qualifiera pour
pour la suite et le perdant par contre
de ce match là sera éliminé de la
compétition parce qu'il a déjà perdu
hier
je suis pas sûr
humm malheureusement je me suis permis
en accord avec lui j'aurais pu en parler
avant là je ne sais pas
et j'aurais dû lui demander avant
si vous voulez venir sur
sur le live
peut-être que je peux lui enlever un
petit message si tu veux je vais essayer
de l'envoyer un petit message
je vais lui envoyer un message
j'ai parti
on verra mais je sais pas si il va
vouloir passer il vient de perdre
alors
donc position assez intéressante paire
de fou encore une fois pour les blancs
ici
j'ai trop été joué thématique qui
empêche les cavaliers de venir bondir
sur les cases F4 ou H4 j'ai aussi h4h5
une possibilité sur le long terme pour
chasser un peu les Cavaliers Noirs ici
et non j'aime beaucoup la profondeur
c'est une fonction de travail il a
quasiment 5000 d'avance à la pendule et
une position avec plein plein de
possibilités pour ces pièces la paire de
fou le centre et éventuellement les
débordements avec H4 H5 j'aime bien la
pose
j'aime beaucoup la pose je sais pas du
tout si
ça va être suffisant moi en tout cas
j'ai confiance en sa position je pense
qu'il peut la gagner
à 5 a été joué pour essayer de taper un
peu sur la colonne ouvert sur le
vis-à-vis
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici
si vous voulez à côté on peut ouvrir
aussi la partie qui reste entre les avis
et
tabac abeilles
la caméra aussi des joueurs
ici donc
deviner l'ouverture c'est comme
ouverture sans
cette ouverture c'est quoi ça
pas simple
c'est pas sympa de vinaigre j'aime bien
se faire ce petit jeu de deviner mais
paire de fou ici
sur les besoins françaises avec le fou
en G2
bizarre comme position je sais pas je
dis rien
c'est cette ok c'est une sorte de
c'est une sorte de ouais catalane
bizarre
tourner
c'est transformé après en structure un
peu française
assez dur à deviner en tout cas très dur
à deviner il y a cavaler des quatre et
j'aime bien les blancs
bien les cases des cavaliers et mon gros
il est un peu ouvert quand même puis
j'ai dû aussi j'ai du F4 j'ai tendance à
préférer la position des blancs
en cliquant en pratique je trouve que
les Blancs ont plus de possibilités que
les noirs
pour du rapide ça m'a l'air pas mal
mais bien sûr c'est
c'est pas du tout pas du tout clair
c'est juste mon ma préférence à moi mais
pas du tout
clair
et les blancs
avec tes blancs
pour arriver au départage si gagne pas
et ben il sera éliminé parce qu'il a
perdu hier son match contre karavana si
il perd encore aujourd'hui il sera élu
de la compétition
donc les 4 4 contre 6
je sais pas si on retourne sur la partie
de Abdou qui avait l'air assez
intéressant toi aussi je pense qu'on va
aller chez Abdou en marche préfère je
préfère vraiment Abdou
je trouve que c'est un match qui est un
peu plus
un peu plus
intéressant que Abdou il a déjà gagné
cette compétition
donc c'est vraiment un joueur de premier
plan même si la Part-Dieu il y a 3-0
contre contre
spectacle ici
donc il faut B6 qui attaque le pion et
en plus c'est
ça par contre ça va être très très mal
comment on est arrivé là
à 5
h
on améliore la position
7 tours c'est un et F5 très grosse faute
à cause de faux B6 qui attaque le pion
et menace pour C7 et en plus après dame
bouge d'un point F5 donc ça a l'air très
très dur je crois que fou B6 c'est une
grosse gaffe de la part de Pavel elianov
très grosse gaffe
et un bout qui est peut-être pouvoir en
profiter pour aller gagner cette partie
qui le qualifierait pour
pour la suite de l'événement donc là on
est vraiment dans le dans le bracket des
loosers et voir qui ont perdu leur match
hier donc la deuxième défaite élimine de
la compétition
donc les deux joueurs n'ont plus le
droit à l'erreur
[Musique]
ok bah ouais mais c'est
donc ça c'est un très bon coup
mais
[Musique]
alors j'avais pas vu ton commentaire à
ceux que ça slow alors je lisais pas ce
qui se passait avant par rapport par
rapport à ce que vous disiez mais on va
quand même éviter
ce langage sur X Oslo donc je te connais
un peu je sais que qu'il y a pas de
souci mais évite quand même ce genre de
de propos et de mots s'il te plaît sur
le sur le sur le chat
non plus je peux pas je peux pas
fermer les yeux je suis obligé d'agir
quand je vois ce genre de langage sur le
chat
[Musique]
non mais c'est juste la la
l'expression que tu as donné
donc juste voilà quoi faut juste essayer
de pas utiliser ce genre de mots sur un
chat d'échec et vous savez que quand
même des enfants on dit qu'il y aura ce
stream c'est pas ma chaîne perso c'est
pas c'est juste comme elle faire donc on
doit s'adapter un peu à tous les publics
qu'on peut avoir qu'on peut avoir sur la
chaîne
donc voilà faut B6 cette va arriver et
ça m'a l'air d'être un peu la
catastrophe il y a eu la même fête de
jouer mais prend à 5 en plus il prend du
pion ce qui crée un pion pas assez fou
cette tour C7 surtout la fuite il y a eu
H4 dans la 8 c'est très compliqué H5
c'est cavalier la chute
qui est possible pas trop envie de
de
laisser faire cavalier G5
et même tour C6 plus tard pas mal aussi
voir tout là maintenant c'est 6 pour
cette pousser un jour ce petit pion en à
6 voir ça fout bouge à 6 à 7 un truc
comme ça là il y a la paire de fou puis
en plus ce pion qui est faible je pense
que c'est juste une formalités pour
Abdou qui va qui va qui va aller sa
partie assez assez facilement
ok donc dame 8
jouer
et
très difficile très très difficile pour
pour pas belle
pas du tout comment il va falloir s'en
sortir
en plus en face c'est Abdou quoi Abdou
généralement les parties gagnantes
c'est pas un genre qui se fait arnaquer
généralement ça ça se passe pas trop
comme ça donc ouais je vois vraiment
vraiment un gros gros point un gros gros
point de la part de Abdou ici qui va
gagner
sa partie c'est tranquillement alors si
je viens voir un peu ce qui se passe
dans la partie d'à côté donc là zavik on
change un petit peu
la zavie qui
alors 5 3 4 5 6 3 4 5 6
OK
donc là
on s'est arrêté à cavaler des 14 C8 il y
a eu trois C8 full français vite et G4
qui est intéressant pour qui c'est de
gagner la case F5 pour son cavalier et
après vous aussi ce qui avait les F5 et
fou prend puis on prend
F6 et en E6 et la partie qui est là au
tourner vachement bien en faveur des
blancs ici il y a plus de 5 en l'air il
y a F6 qui est une menace apparemment
selon l'ordinateur
était une très grosse gaffe on voit
qu'il y a un point d'interrogation
et après je vous comprends F5 il fallait
bouger le roi mais la position est
extrêmement compliquée
en un coup assez facile et apparemment
après ouais égale
pour les blancs mais c'est hyper dur à
comprendre ça va elle prend H6 alors
quand même pas mal pour les blancs mais
apparemment ça va donc bah nous on n'est
pas des ordinateurs et des humains
c'est hyper danger de la part des blancs
et après fils de 6 bah écoutez il y a un
pion il y a un pion passé pour les
blancs ici avec les pions des 5 qui est
aussi une très grosse faiblesse et aussi
des cases blanches qui sont accessibles
ici par exemple ici
damage 5 et sur Damas 8 je pourrais
manger et manger en dessin
ça a l'air quand même pas mal du tout
pour pour les blancs après il y a foutu
reposer enfin attention que souvent ça
fait ça fait nuit en fin de partie mais
j'ai encore quand même des pions
d'avance et donc je pense que ça va être
une victoire assez nette de la part de
2000 azalik qui risque d'arriver plus
tard au à un départage
un des partages dans ce match
donc en dessin qui arrive je sais qui
arrive tous les pions vont tomber
même tour des vides pour changer les
tours et avoir cette finale de même ça
c'est dur
c'est ce pion qui était proche de la
promotion je dois vraiment le garder et
j'ai un peu passé ici je vais me créer
un peu passé ici et je pense il suffira
par je pense ça va gagner facilement
pour les blancs quand même
je pense ça va être facile pour les
blancs
c'est la partie on a jusque là il y a 48
secondes pour aller noir noir absolument
défendre cette partie en cas de nul
en cas de nul
les Noirs se qualifient pour le deuxième
tour des perdant
mais en cas d'égalité
et
il y aura un départage en Armageddon
juste après
donc pris surprend j'ai échec je prends
la
et pareil c'est ici ça va gagner assez
facile pour les blanches j'ai
l'impression
et l'autre position de Abdou on tourne
un peu hein
de de
bien maîtriser quand même cette position
c'est assez compliqué on s'est arrêté
par là je vais assez vite
tours c'est un Eka damage 5 rois je suis
prise F4 et ça me va c'est hyper
compliqué il y a plein de sacrifices de
partout les noirs qui veulent essayer de
tenter leur chance mais il faut prendre
marchera pas
qui veut tenter la chance d'en surprise
là tout F4 attaque le pion H4 c'est la
partie
alors je suis passé je suis passé à ami
ouais c'est ça mais
[Musique]
mais
ça a pas encore été validé par la fille
mais ça va arriver alors il y a pas du
tout il y a pas du tout de problème
sur xoslo en tout cas pas pour moi
t'inquiète pas c'est juste le mot que tu
as écrit qui n'est pas valable sur une
chaîne publique comme celle-là donc je
sais que moi je sais que moi je m'en
fous
etc mais je sais bien que c'était
enfantin et que tu voulais même pas
embêter les gens il y a pas de souci
là-dessus mais c'est juste que c'est un
langage qui est pas approprié sur cette
chaîne là c'est juste pour ça que je le
dis c'est pas du tout bah oui je suis
désolé c'est pas un mot qui est qui est
autorise sur cette chaîne publique et
c'est juste ça mais je te reproche rien
de rien de la méchant juste si le
vocabulaire sur cette chaîne là qui
n'est pas autorisé alors sur ma chaîne
perso bah alors là tu peux y aller il y
a pas de problème tu vois on rigole mais
ici même si je sais que c'est une blague
même si je sais qu'il y a pas de
problème c'est juste ce langage qui
n'est pas ici voilà c'est tout
c'est juste ça que je viens mais après
il y a pas de problème je sais que très
bien que tu es pas venu pour causer des
ennuis ou quoi que ce soit et je pensais
absolument pas rigueur encore une fois
je peux je sais que tu es souvent sur la
chaîne je sais que tu es toujours actif
etc il y a aucun son il y a aucun
problème là-dessus je te préviens juste
que ce langage sur chescom il faut
éviter mais je te l'ai pas le meilleur
méchante il faut éviter ce langage c'est
tout
alors moi j'ai trois et là il y a des
échecs mais bon j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a plus rien du tout
donc tout reprend ton coin F6
et là c'est terminé
j'ai 5 et c'est Matt sur le chéquier
c'est ma solution qui est parce qu'ici
regardez après la prise ici voilà clarté
et après la prise ici roi je sais ça
fait cavaler le 5 et chaque émote ok
donc Abdou qui qui élimine et les meuf
de la compétition ça c'est clair et
maintenant on va voir un petit peu
l'autre
l'autre partie
c'est là avec qui est absolument gagnant
et s'il gagne cette partie et ben il va
arriver au départage c'est gagné ça y
est c'est fini et la partie maintenant
est gagnée donc on va avoir un
département
et tabacabay d'ici quelques instants je
vais attendre que qu'on me dise sur
slack
ouais je viens de l'avoir dans ça
maintenant on va avoir du coup bientôt
sur slack les infos des départages je
vous rappelle que c'est le départage qui
se joue
qui se joue en un magasin ce qui veut
dire qu'en fait et ben les joueurs ils
vont
ils vont donner un temps d'accord c'est
par une sorte d'enchère donc les
douleurs vont rejoindre un temps ils
vont dire avec combien de temps tu veux
jouer avec les Noirs dans dans cette
partie et le joueur qui aura dit le
temps le plus bas et ben aura
les noirs et pourra faire nul alors pour
un cheval de faire mieux là et en cas de
égalité c'est noir qui gagneront et qui
passeront autour suivant donc là la
partie qui va toujours en vie au moins
10 minutes donc je vais prendre ma
première pause si vous le voulez bien et
je reviens 5-10 minutes dès qu'on aura
la suite de la compétition dès qu'on
aura le temps des joueurs et la partie
qui va
commencer donc je vous dis à tout de
suite et je vous envoie les pubs de los
sponsor vous savez que ce tournoi est
rempli de sponsors je vous envoie la
première à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour pour cette Armageddon
qui va commencer à l'instant entre tabac
Tabeille avec les Blancs contre
contre Denis lasalik les temps je vais
vous les donner donc il y a eu je vous
rappelle des enchères et je trouve ça
intéressant de voir que tabac tabeuil a
demandé 14 minutes 50
alors que là David a demandé 9 minutes
20 pour avoir pour avoir les Noirs donc
la David qu'il est OK pour avoir les
noirs avec 9 20 entre 15 minutes et
amine ça va tabac il voulait absolument
avoir
les blancs de ce que j'ai compris donc
avec les blancs
de Londres ça a commencé à l'instant je
sais pas si vous voyez ouais je crois
que c'est bon
donc voilà
on doit absolument gagner que les blancs
en cas de nul c'est les noirs qui
qu'est-ce qualifie pour poursuivre pour
suivre l'aventure
il y a un discord
là c'est pas ma chaîne perso c'est la
chaîne de discorde
par contre moi j'ai ma chaîne pour tout
d'ailleurs qui sont qui sont sur
sur
le chat que ce soit sur Youtube c'est
soit sur sur
twitch n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir
donc à nous follow sur la fenêtre comme
FR et je suis aussi d'ailleurs moi sur
sur twitch et sur Youtube donc d'abord
aussi à me rejoindre peut-être Yuma si
tu peux mettre les
liens peut-être éventuellement très
gentil de me mettre les liens de ma
chaîne de YouTube et twitch pour ceux
qui avaient envie de venir découvrir ce
que j'ai fait
mais là je suis sur cheeseccom FR donc
on va aussi mettre les liens parce que
là vous avez YouTube et tweet donc
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à nous follow
pour être au courant de tout ce qui peut
de tout ce qu'on fait en fait tout
simplement des vidéos des shorts des
lives etc soyez un peu au courant de
tout ça
donc dans cette position c'est un
magasin qui veut dire que c'est la
dernière partie de ce match et si un
gagnant le gagnant se qualifie pour la
suite mais en cas de qualité c'est le
noir qui se qualifieront pour la suite
les Noirs beaucoup moins de temps que
les Blancs vous allez voir on a commencé
avec 15 minutes pour les blancs contre
c'était combien c'était 9 minutes 20 il
me semble pour les noirs
et mets en échange les noirs peuvent
faire mieux donc c'est assez compliqué
les blancs absolument gagner et en plus
de temps la pendule c'est du chaos il y
a pas de temps
il y a pas d'un ajout de temps donc pour
l'instant
les noirs on joue très vite ils ont
dépensé environ 30 secondes vous êtes
parti pour avoir une bonne position
il y a un discord qui ont toute la commu
fr
d'échec je crois pas
je ne crois pas
donc cavaler des six
cavaler les deux
systèmes de Londres et d'ailleurs ça
structure qu'on peut aussi obtenir avec
la avec la karaoké
ce cavalier et on peut imaginer ce
cavaler venir revenir en C5 via D3 pour
après devenir soit en E5 soit en F4 et
voilà c'est ce qui fait
et aussi B4 des fois qui peut être aussi
un une possibilité pour venir vraiment
construire le cavalence à 5 par contre
si on joue B4 c'est un programme
de garder la dame
moi j'aime bien la garder les dents
généralement dame de 4 je sais pas si
c'est bien mais les blancs doivent
gagner la partie donc gagner les dames
ça aurait pas été stupide comme décision
en tout cas
caisse Var qui est qui habite dans le
Var peut-être qu'on se connaît de ce
soir peut-être qu'on se connaît
parce que moi j'habitais toute ma vie
entre Nice et Cannes c'est pas très loin
du Var il y a plein de tournois qui
étaient organisés à Toulon à Hyères La
Farlède dans toutes ces petites villes
là-bas dans le Var et j'en ai joué un
nombre de tournois là-bas
donc on se connaît peut-être d'ailleurs
que ça va
je suis un pion qui pousse faire la
huitième
noircisses contre nous
je sais pas si on se connaît
toi tu le sais tu le connais moi je sais
pas si je te connais parce que moi je te
vois pas mais c'est possible
et c'est là où tu as de luxe salut à toi
ah c'est gilet noir un G6
je ne te connais pas
et peut-être qui fait qui fait de la
cuisine c'est la belle découverte de la
dernière fois nous a fait des belles
arrêts qui nous ont envoyé sur discord
d'ailleurs il faut que je fasse aussi
pour t'envoyer
Caval F3 vous allez penser que je suis
que je suis que je suis bon en cuisine
mais en fait c'est pas vrai
juste c'est un truc que je sais faire et
je le fais
mais c'est pas mon point fort du tout
allez
[Musique]
on sait pas
notre plat
en train de voir si on se connaît alors
on va on va
on va renommer ce stream sur un petit
rencontre sur cheesecom
le F3 G4 très intéressant j'aime bien la
position blanche en figurez-vous parce
que il a oui il a fait des cartes que
j'avais dit tout à l'heure on a un beau
cavalier en
en C5 et un beau aussi cavalier en E5
non aussi en des cases vous voyez il y a
des cannes des cases pour les cavaliers
noirs aussi et il y a quand même une
pression avec G4 qui peut qui peut
avancer la roue G3 et après la pousser
ben j'ai la colonne F pour ma tour pour
mettre deux tours éventuellement j'ai
aussi un pion H qui peut partir là-bas
et c'est plus tard se créer un pion
passé je trouve que la position blanche
elle est en tout cas plus simple à jouer
que la production noire
mais après tout reste possible dans la
position
les blancs joueurs pose en tout cas ça
va t'abais pas l'air d'être bien content
et là ce qui se passe j'ai l'impression
c'est que si on fait G5 qui risque d'y
avoir un coup comme cavalier F5 qui peut
être intéressant et fourchette entre le
roi et la tour et
et si je même si je prends ça pareil
aussi un problème sur la case de 4
c'est-à-dire que si je prends là et ben
puis on prend il y aura un cavalier le
cadre cavalier prend cavaler prend à
faire trois lots sur le pion C3 donc
c'est compliqué
plein de choses qui arrivent mais c'est
le cavalier 6 qui vient d'arriver peut
poser problème en tout cas dans la
position de ta bataille
voilà un petit peu ce qui se passe ici
alors moi j'ai pas de spécialité moi
j'ai pas de spécialité du tout
un stage
mais moi j'ai pas de spécialité juste
que je sais faire de trois trucs
mais
voilà non je sais pas bon je suis pas
bon du tout ne pensez pas que je suis un
chef cuisinier un loin de là
alors roi F3 et ca va les prendre c'est
5 qui va probablement arriver alors là
il y a eu tatouage de qui va arriver
voilà dans ce cas là toujours la
possibilité de pouvoir faire H5 un jour